[Music]
- Terry timer just disappear overnight
it's very not unheard of he's crazy
no I'd like to introduce James Harvey a
man he prays to God for 50 years same
prayer every night God please let me win
the lottery
year after year after year after year
please finally an angel goes to God and
he says this man has been praying so
long why don't you let him win
God says I'd love to help him out but
he's never bought a lottery ticket hear
about your husband's new fan work ethic
Jesus Tarly office golden boy it just
flipped a couple of houses got yourself
promoted don't let it go to your head
I went on a date last night she said
she'd rather be deaf than blood
somebody got represent now that you
deserted us I heard what you did had
done to school the kid needed a break
you don't get to do that
mom said you went to a party and didn't
take her what's like with her like you
wouldn't done the same thing yeah the
chance would you the chance to get what
you want
I didn't realize things were so bad
you're jealous if you leave you can't
come back you know that right
she's gonna take you back now